Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at The Round
Table of Dim Lighting,
we are catching up with
one another and with you
about our recent trips that we took.
I went to Florida for parents weekend
to visit my freshman
in college son, Locke.
This was your first visit
since you dropped him off-
Since dropping him off.
... at college.
Yeah.
So that's a big deal.
That's a milestone moment.
You, Jessie, and Shepherd, you all went.
Yeah, we decided to not
leave our 14 year old alone
and to bring him with us,
which ended up being
an interesting choice.
I mean, we would've never not done that,
but I just have a POV on what it's like-
That normal choice
became very interesting?
Well, I have a POV on
what it's like to hang out
with a 14 year old-
I would hope you do
... that you might find interesting.
And you had a little bit more
pleasurable trip, I assume.
Oh yeah, definitely.
Christy and I had a getaway to Big Sur.
About this time last year, I believe,
is when we went to Big Sur.
So I'm not gonna rehash.
There was a decent amount of overlap.
Last time, there was a lot of rain
on the tin roof of the cabin,
none of that this time.
But still a bunch of beautiful trees.
But there were a couple
of things that happened,
a person that I met that
I could not have predicted
that I would meet deep in the forest.
Okay.
And an encounter,
an intimate encounter
unlike any I've ever had
that did not really involve Christy.
Oh my.
How's that for a teaser?
I'm excited.
You actually look kind of
tired, you don't look excited.
Well, I am tired.
I mean, that's the thing.
We work hard, man.
I saw a few comments, I
can't remember where it was.
I tend to not read comments
and I find out why whenever I do.
But back when you took a vacation
and then I took a vacation
and we talked about them on Ear Biscuits
and because we are YouTubers
and because we like to be sensational
about the way we title things
and the way we describe things
because it's called entertainment,
we called it Worst Vacation Ever, right?
And then there were a
few people who are like,
I don't want to hear two rich guys
complain about their vacation
that they can afford to go on.
Which I appreciate that perspective,
but I just want to remind you
that we talk about these
things for your entertainment.
If you're not entertained,
there's many other options
on the Internet.
Oh.
Don't send a packing, man.
Please don't go.
Please like us.
What I'm saying is we work very hard
for your entertainment,
and also for the lifestyle
that we would like to live.
And that involves doing things like
going and visiting your children
when they go off to college
or taking your wife on
a nice little trip away.
We're not going to apologize
about those choices.
And when we do them,
we're gonna come back and
we're gonna talk about them
on this podcast.
Oh, .
You have the privilege
and the freedom to comment
about how you feel like we're
too privileged rich dudes
who complain about things,
because we are too privileged rich dudes
who do complain about things
for your entertainment.
And we're going to continue to do that.
We'll complain about
the things that bug us,
and we'll celebrate the
things that please us,
and you're welcome to
come along for the ride.
But we're gonna do what we wanna do.
That's one take.
I think the other take is I'm like,
ooh, I'm cringing inside,
'cause I'm very self-conscious
about, okay, having money.
It's a hang up of mine.
I really-
I wasn't planning on talking about this,
but you talked about how I look tired
and the reason I look tired is
because I'm a middle-aged man
who works his off running a company
and making entertainment.
And then you feel like
you have to apologize for
complaining about your vacation
which you only did for
entertainment purposes.
Right.
I get that, I totally get it.
I am not disagreeing.
There is something about
the evolving relationship
that we have with Mythical
Beast, casual fans,
I'm making a list now, just
interloping commenters,
and sometimes,
so there's different categories of people
that we can get feedback from.
Sometimes you don't know
how to weight that feedback.
So on one hand, I don't wanna be like,
well, I don't listen to any feedback.
And I'm not saying that.
But like I was telling
you, I was listening to-
I think we demonstrated that
we listened to quite a lot of feedback
and take that into account.
If anything, a healthy exercise for us,
and I think this is maybe
what you're kind of embodying
at this point is that since
our tendency is to be so,
sensitive isn't the right word,
but there's a high fidelity
to the give and take
between us and the vocal Mythical Beast,
the feedback that we get.
It is very important, it's very valuable.
If anything, we need to guard
against overweighting that
and not not going with our gut sometimes,
or not being ourselves or saying,
I'm doing this for entertainment value
or I'm doing this to reach somebody,
but it can be misunderstood
Yeah, I agree with that.
I was just telling you that,
I don't really listen to Joe Rogan,
but Rick Rubin was a guest,
and I listen to everything
that Rick Rubin shows up on.
That guy is so inspiring to me.
So on the way in,
they were at a point in their conversation
where Rick was asking Rogan
about what kept him grounded
and what, despite
experiencing success and fame,
what keeps him sane.
I think it was less of
grounded and more of sane,
'cause they were talking about,
there's a lot that goes along
with being in the public eye,
being successful, being
subject to so much scrutiny.
And again, I'm not saying anything
about Joe Rogan's point of view
or stance on anything here,
but his response was he works out,
he does his cold plunge stuff,
which I know you're getting into that too.
And so I thought this would
really resonate with you.
And then he said,
"I don't read what people say
or think about me at all, at all."
Yep.
That's a privilege.
That is a wild privilege.
You can do that as a really
famous music producer.
You cannot do that as an Internet person.
Well, no, this was Joe Rogan
talking, not Rick Rubin.
Oh, okay.
So Joe doesn't listen to
what anybody says about him.
And it shows.
Yeah, and it shows.
We're different people than him.
So I think it would show-
We approach things in a different way,
But also if we didn't listen to anything,
I'd like to think we're
true enough to ourselves
and what we're putting out into the world,
that that's what Mythical
Beasts are connecting with
so that even if we didn't
listen to any feedback,
we would still be in this
safe zone of we're still us,
you're still you, we still
have this connection.
But, and I actually don't
know what the but is.
Well, I see, where you're going with this.
I don't know my point is, so
you tell me where I'm going.
I think that there is a
difference between accountability
and cowering in fear about being yourself.
So for instance-
And I see that in myself sometimes.
We have a big team and they
do read all the comments
and they know exactly
what people are saying.
Good point.
The team is listening and then telling us.
So-
The team is listening.
... recent example, we
did an episode of GMM
where it was our,
can we follow directions
in a different language?
And we decided we wanted to
feature American Sign Language
on that episode.
And we had a deaf person
lined up to be the person
to do sign language, because again,
representation is important to us
and we were like we want
to get a deaf person
to actually do this.
They, unfortunately-
And our team, and by the
way, our team knew that.
It's not something we needed to tell them.
The GMM team already knew that
so that's what they were working on.
Of course.
It's not something we had to like,
well make sure you do it this way.
Yeah, and so-
They were going about it in
a way that I feel good about.
That person was unable to make it.
And of course our
production schedule is crazy
and very tight.
And so Matt Carney's
friend was in town who,
you saw the guy who was on the episode
and his brother was deaf
and he had to learn,
the whole family had
to learn sign language
in order to communicate with the brother.
So we were like, oh, that's a cool story.
And it's not exactly what we wanted,
which was a deaf person,
but we made a decision
to still move forward
to be able to have ASL
featured on the show.
And of course, we got immediate feedback
from a number of people about
how this was not inclusive
to the deaf community.
And you know what?
We totally understand that and
we listen to that feedback,
and I think moving forward, it'll be like,
okay, even though we know the backstory,
which is we had somebody who
was ready to go who was deaf
and then we ended up
using a non deaf person
or a hearing person,
because that's a difficult thing
to explain and contextualize
and we did run the risk
of making the deaf
community feel excluded,
maybe we should have
taken a different tack.
And this is great feedback
and we'll taken it into
account moving forward.
And we commented to the
people on Twitter who said it,
we commented on a TikTok video.
That's accountability
and that is something that we listen to.
But me being a person
of privilege and wealth
because of all the success
that we have garnered
for reasons that are a lot,
we're just very fortunate and very lucky
and right timing and
things have gone right,
and we do live an unusual lifestyle.
but that is the life that we live.
That is the life that we
have found ourselves in,
is being the CEOs of this
big company that's doing well
and having figured out this Internet game
and having the ability to
work really, really hard
all the time,
but then take much needed breaks
and then come on this
podcast and talk about them.
I understand that if you
are not in a situation
where you can afford a vacation
or you don't have a job that pays well,
you don't have a job that you even enjoy,
that it may be difficult to listen to us
to say that we do enjoy our job
and we do make a lot of money
and we do go on vacation.
And again, what I'm saying is,
you have the right if
that's triggering for you
to not listen,
but I'm not going to
not talk about my life
because my life might
be triggering to you.
And I just think that there's a place
where you have to draw the line.
I wanna be sensitive to it
and I don't wanna make this podcast
all about two rich guys talking
about all the rich guy stuff
that they do, 'cause that would be stupid.
But if you-
And we don't do that, I don't think.
But the podcast is about our lives.
I mean that is it, this
is what you signed up for,
this is what you click for.
Yeah so this is us being ourselves,
and so I'm not gonna
apologize for being myself,
But we are two middle-aged
dudes from rural North Carolina
who have changed a whole hell of a lot
over the course of the past 20 years.
And there's still things
that we're learning
and there's things that we don't know.
And so when our more informed,
more sensitive audience
lets us know where we've
missed the mark, we do listen.
But I don't think that two guys
talking about their vacation
and if I had a bad vacation
complaining about that vacation,
that's a place where I'm not
gonna let people bully me
into not talking about it.
That's all I'm gonna say about that.
I was thinking the same thing this morning
when I was brushing my teeth
with ground up diamonds.
I've found that the abrasive properties
of the most expensive diamonds
really do a great job cleaning my teeth.
Yeah, I found that as well, Link.
Right,
Of course, you're using
my leftover diamonds.
Yeah, because I'm a cheap skate
Because I get them first.
Right, I'll buy them off of you because-
I put them in my mouth first.
I don't pay retail.
My children use them
then they're sent to you.
I am still a cheap skate.
So this is how we started this podcast.
Yeah, well-
Should we just keep going?
Should the whole podcast be about like-
No.
Well, on your feedback.
You know why it shouldn't be?
Because there's a lot of people,
and I see you and I
respect you, who are like,
guys, you don't have to talk
about this, we don't care.
I understand that and I appreciate you
that you don't feel the need to comment,
but, I wasn't planning
on talking about this.
I was gonna give you guys a bear update,
which I'll move on to now.
Should we talk about
Vote Like a Beast first?
Yeah, we should.
Because I mean, if we wanna
make this more controversial,
let's tell them who to vote for.
Okay, well, we don't do that.
No.
We did create votelikeabeast.com.
And the midterm elections
are extremely pivotal,
don't underestimate your local state
and the national midterm election,
what is it, November 8th?
So, rapidly approaching.
We created a Vote Like A Beast
to not tell you how to vote,
but to help you become informed
on how you want to vote.
You can check your registration,
you can get all your affairs in order,
and you can, in terms
of your point of view,
so that you can be educated
to vote your heart, mind, soul, toenails,
whatever it is you vote with.
Votelikeabeast.com.
Go for it.
Ayt?
Okay.
I recently talked about my trip,
yeah, me and my trips,
where Jessie and I went with
friends, Lance and Lacey,
to a cabin for the weekend
and there was a bear that ended up-
A bear drove your car.
... getting into my car.
Apparently, there is a bear network.
They are communicating with one another,
and at least one of them
listens to this podcast.
Uh-oh.
This is my theory.
What?
This is my theory because
you will not believe-
So far it sounds like a sound theory.
... what happened to me.
As you know, we live in Los Angeles,
and we live in relative close proximity
to mountains that contain wildlife.
You've had encounters with bears.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I've never had an
encounter with a bear.
In fact-
At my trash can, in the dark,
I had a face off with a bear.
On my way back from the airport,
the Uber driver was saying,
as he came up into the
neighborhood was like,
"You guys ever see bears up here?"
As I was coming back from
my trip to see Locke,
and I was like, "Nah, I mean,
our good friends who live
about a mile away or so,
they've seen them, but
we've never seen bears."
And I was like, "As a matter of fact,
I've never seen a bear
outside of the zoo."
'Cause even the bear that
I had an encounter with,
I didn't see it.
You just saw-
Lance and Lacey saw the bear,
and then I saw the evidence
of the bear in the car
and on the porch.
The sanitation people can
give you a special trash can
that is bear proof.
That's how pervasive bears could be
in certain times of the
year in our neighborhood.
Well, interestingly-
Yeah, so I kind of assumed
that you'd seen a bear too.
Your house, the back of your house
touches a wildlife area where
a bear could be at home.
I'm more in a insulated neighborhood
with rows of houses around me.
Right, which is why I'm better than you.
Right, and so I always thought to myself,
when my trash can gets knocked over,
I was just picturing three raccoons
standing on top of each
other or something.
Hey, they can do it.
They're so smart.
And cute, and vicious, and hungry.
But my trash can has been
knocked over a few times
and then the trash has
been rummaged through.
But I was just like, this
is a real smart raccoon,
'cause I've seen a bunch of raccoons.
Well, Jessie and I are coming
back from a birthday dinner
that she had for me,
which I will tell you about
later the other night, and-
Oh, is this the tortilla
picture that was tweeted?
Yeah, yeah, oh, I've got
way more pictures than that.
Oh, yes.
And we're pulling up to our driveway,
and there's a little space
in between our driveway
and our neighbor's driveway.
Their house is currently under renovation
and the driveway has got
all kinds of crap in it
just from stuff they tore
away from the house and stuff.
And walking down the
road in front of my house
is a giant bear.
And I don't mean like,
the one you told me about
was a juvenile bear, right?
Mm, it-
This was a fat, giant bear.
I don't know how to estimate
bear size, but 500 pounds?
It was massive.
Yeah, I have not seen a bear that big.
And so I immediately, and he walked up-
What time of night was this?
10 o'clock?
9:30 maybe
Wow.
And he walks up the neighbor's driveway
and I immediately, of
course, get out the phone.
I actually wanted to get out of the car,
but Jessie didn't let me.
But this is the video that I captured,
and prepare to be disappointed
because I pulled up as far
as I could in the driveway
and then got this,
Oh, it's carnage in their driveway.
Oh, my gosh.
What?
Are you getting him?
Yeah.
You getting him?
He's huge.
He's real big.
"He's real big."
He is real big.
She's from Fuquay.
I'm gonna tell you right now.
That is a big freaking bear, dude.
Yeah, it's hard to to tell.
That was just his head.
Yeah, I would say he's
1/3 bigger than the bear
that I had to face off with
in my backyard one time.
So now the only animal that I haven't seen
that I know is in the
neighborhood is a mountain lion.
I haven't seen a mountain lion.
I've seen a good amount
of long-legged bobcats
and a whole lot of long-legged coyotes.
Seen a bobcat at the creative house.
Yeah.
Seen deer all the time.
I love seeing a bobcat, that's cool.
That was the first bobcat I've ever seen.
First and only.
Mountain lion, isn't that crazy though?
I mean, my neighbor's seen some of those.
So anyway-
So now, you think that
they're talking to each other
and they're-
Well, all I can say is
I have not seen a bear
up until this point.
I talk about bears
publicly on the Internet,
and bear shows up and he had been,
yeah, I mean I'm not a detective,
but I believe he had been
up to my trash to inspect it
and we hadn't put
anything in the trash yet.
He he's not following along,
he's not following the schedule very well.
We had been out of town.
I always forget when to
put the trash out too.
I have a reminder.
And that is a reminder
to then tell my son that.
Yeah.
That's what I need.
That's his job.
I just look at when all
my neighbors put out
their trash cans while I'm driving in.
So leaving for the trip,
sometimes the most important
part of a trip is going.
And sometimes that's
really difficult to do.
I think back to that RV trip we had
where getting out of my driveway
was literally a test of
will and human ingenuity.
You remember that?
Mm-hmm.
I'm a big fan of filling up
with gas the night before.
The last thing you want to do is pack up,
get really excited to get on the road.
and then you start getting on the road
and you realize, oh we,
we gotta stop for gas
before we get on the road.
There's something like-
It's like a stutter.
Is it a dad energy?
Is it a man thing?
I don't know what it is about,
I don't, I want to get on
the road, I wanna get going.
Let's get going.
There's a lot of standing
around the house.
Like, you ready?
You ready?
I packed everything last night.
I packed it in my brain the night before,
kind of a thing.
But this is just you and your wife?
It's just me and Christy, so it-
And she's pretty on board with,
I imagine that she packs well in advance.
I'm dealing with, my family,
man, it's a war zone.
You know the neighbor's driveway.
I'm the least organized person in our duo,
but I am by far the most
organized person in my family.
And so know I'm packed at 9:00 PM.
Christy and I are very,
we're very much on the same page,
but I will say she didn't fill up the gas
the day before we're taking her car.
So had to pull over and
fill it up at the bottom,
before one mile into the trip.
I'm like, let's just get it outta the way.
'cause once we get going,
I just wanna be going.
And thank goodness we did that
because I don't have a little
lever inside of the car
that you pull to open the gas cap.
you just walk up to the
gas cap on the outside
and you push it, you push
it in and then it opens,
the flap opens-
And there's no cap.
There actually is still a cap underneath.
Oh, interesting.
In our car.
I pushed on the thing, nothing.
Pushed on the thing, nothing.
Pushed harder on the thing,
I couldn't get it open.
Now, we had half a tank of gas,
but I wanted a full tank of gas
And you want the ability to gas in later.
But more importantly, I want that ability.
and I'm like, oh gosh,
I'm glad we're still here.
Across the street is the
guy who does our service
on the car.
And Christy's like, "Well,,
take it over to him,
maybe he can pop it."
We take it over there and he can't pop it.
And he's like, "Well,
just leave it with me."
And I was like, "Well we
don't have another car.
We're going on a trip,
we don't have another car
that we can take."
And we start taking everything
outta the back of the car
so that he can see if he can get access
from the inside to the
backside of the thing.
This is crazy.
And I'm like, yeah,
it's just, it's, I'm ...
And then I'm like, oh no, this can't,
I'm looking so forward to
this trip, I need this so bad.
This can't happen.
So while they're rummaging
through the inside,
these two mechanics who
are stopping they're doing
to help us 'cause they know Christy
'cause we get so much work done there.
It's good to have a mechanic you can trust
and they know your face if
not your name and your wallet.
So I was like, I can't, I can't do this.
So then I just started wedging my fingers
in between the door and
the fuselage of the car,
and I'm like, something has to be done.
something has to-
You're prying at this point.
I'm prying.
And then so I pull it hard
and then all of a sudden,
pop.
I just ripped the
outside of the body part,
the smooth body part of the gas cap thing.
I just ripped that whole sucker off.
The door came off?
The door came off in my hand.
But it was just the facade of it.
So then underneath,
there's this apparatus,
the thing that's actually broken
that you have to push on.
And then at that point,
they could take a flathead
screwdriver and pop that open.
And then he said,
"Well, because there's
a gas cap underneath it,
don't push that thing all the way back in
and you'll be fine.
Just drive with this thing
just kind of like flapping
open a little bit."
So, but Christy and I both
had a similar thought.
We were like, okay now we
can get back on the road,
we can get gas, we went
back over and got gas
and we're both independently
thinking the same thing.
Which is strange
'cause I don't like
thinking this type of stuff
'cause I don't think I believe this way.
But I was like, is this a
sign that we shouldn't go
on this trip?
Wow, okay.
It's like-
How did that come up?
We talked about it a little bit later.
Christy was like, "I kind of
feel well we shouldn't go."
A bad omen.
I was like, nope, I'm
not believing in omens.
This is not happening.
I believe in going on
this trip, nothing else.
But I got a little nervous.
And then it is a six-hour
drive to Big Sur.
And we stop for lunch,
we get back on the road,
we're driving a little bit
further and then I'm like,
"You know what?
Let's switch so you
can drive a little bit.
We're about to hit the curvy stuff."
She gets real car sick.
So it's like driving should help.
Right.
I pullover on the side of the road,
basically in the middle of nowhere,
we were about to lose cell service.
Again, thank goodness I
pulled over where we did
because the moment I got out of the car
to then switch sides,
the car just died completely.
All the power just died.
Car wouldn't crank.
You didn't turn the car off, It just died.
I didn't turn the car off, it knocked off.
And I don't know, a 2018 Volkswagen Atlas,
it's not supposed to knock off.
And so here we are, we're on
the PCH, we're on highway one,
just starting the scenic drive.
Beautiful, beautiful.
It's so beautiful.
And we're sitting there,
I don't know what to do.
I feel very inadequate.
But then everything that
Christy's telling me
doesn't make sense.
It's like, I feel like what
you're telling me right now,
like, "Can you put it in park."
"Try to use my key."
"It doesn't see the key,
it says that the battery's dead."
Okay, I guess the battery's dead,
but why of a sudden would you just stop
on the side of the road and
the battery would be dead?
And so we start fighting.
Christy and I never,
we don't raise our voices with each other.
We never yell at each other.
But it quickly escalated
on this side of the road
where she's like, "Call AAA.
Go ahead and call AAA."
I'm like, "I'm just
gonna sit here and think,
I need to think for a second
and need gather my thoughts."
She's like, "Well you can
call AAA and then think.
And so that way we're waiting even less."
And like she's making
good points at this point.
And she's like,
but then I ended up doing
this thing where she was like,
"Just, well, I'm trying to help."
And I'm like, "I'm trying to help.
I'm trying to help."
This is how toddler I got.
I was just so, it was
just like feeling like
this is ruining our trip,
I am totally inadequate to fix this.
I just felt, I don't
know, it was just like,
I felt like I was really in my head
and this is all an excuse
because there's no good reason.
And half of it was, and I told Christy,
10 minutes later, once
everything was resolved
I was like,
"It was so funny how we
were yelling at each other.
I wanna let you know that
I was halfway joking.
I thought it would be funny."
You told her that you were joking.
That I was halfway joking.
'Cause I was, I was like,
" don't know what to do."
It's like I was yelling
like that, literally.
It wasn't like-
Yeah, that's half a joke.
It wasn't like I was angry at her.
And she was yelling too,
and then she just went
to the back of the truck.
Was she joke yelling?
She was joking, I mean, a little bit too.
It was one of those things
where it was just like,
because it was just funny
that we were on the side
of the road yelling and-
Christy texted us at this point.
There was a part of us that knew that.
That's why I'm not
embarrassed to tell this story
because it was so embarrassing at the time
'cause it was just silly.
Well, she texted.
It didn't get that, no
one was about to cry.
She just went, but she was like,
"Fine, I'll just go to the back of the SUV
and I will just stand there
if you think you got this."
We called AAA and they came
and they charged the battery.
It was that simple.
What did she text you at that point?
'Cause she wasn't talking to me.
"Don't talk to me."
Oh, well, the first text she sent
was not to our four-way text.
'Cause she didn't want me to see
what she was saying about me.
So let's see what she said.
It was probably just me
and Christy and Jessie.
I don't know, I can't find the text.
But it was essentially,
we're on the side of the road
yelling at each other right now.
She didn't say joke yelling.
I will say at the moment she did not say
that you were joke yelling.
After the guy,
it was the type of thing
that neither one of us
had to apologize.
It didn't get that real.
It was this kind of like
ridiculous joke yelling type thing.
It's like, "Leave me alone."
And the guy from AAA showed up?
AAA showed up.
Alternator?
Nope, the battery was completely dead,
and come to find out,
we just needed a new battery.
They can do that right on the spot.
But for some reason, they didn't-
Didn't have your battery?
No, they didn't say I need a new battery.
But Christy has since
taken it into the dealer.
And by the way, me ripping off
the outside of that gas cap.
Helped a lot,
$300.
Oh, okay.
That was a 300 dollar-
Yeah, cars man.
But-
So they just jumped you at that point
and got you going?
Because apparently the
part that I ripped off,
the manufacturer just
ships you an unpainted one,
so you have to install it.
Well, that could be cool.
And then you have to get a body shop
to paint just that thing.
Or you could leave it unpainted
to call it a joke cover.
A joke gas hole?
This is my joke gas hole.
So we're adding this
to my gas hole stories.
I've had some really
embarrassing gas hole stories
over the course of my career.
You can look those up.
You have had a lot of
issues with that car though.
Yeah, we gotta get rid of it.
I mean, it could be a lemon
because, I mean, I don't
know anything about,
I don't know much about cars or car brands
or which one-
I gotta get a Rolls.
Yeah, and the ones that run on diamonds?
Yeah.
The diamond burning Rolls SUV.
And then we can just make a whole podcast
about your Rolls.
Yeah, you see where I'm going.
So at that point we were
like, should we turn around?
Should we turn around?
Because if we get to the
place where we're go,
we drive three more hours, is
the battery gonna die again?
All we did was charge it back up.
And it had something-
That's what I'd be worried about,
especially on that road man.
Yeah 'cause there's no cell service
for the next two and a half hours.
And then you finally get
to the place you're going.
It was like, we cannot stop
the car, we cannot get out,
we cannot do anything
until we get to the place we're going
so that then somebody can jump
us again in to get back home.
Right, yeah, you have to
basically slow the car down,
and then you get out of the car
and Christy puts her hand on the wheel
and moves over and then
you go use the bathroom
and then she comes back
and does the same thing.
The car never stops,
that's how you do that.
We didn't, I just drove
and neither one of us used the bathroom.
Okay, or you just pee in your pants.
I held it.
But it turned out not to be a bad omen
because everything else was great
and even the battery was
fine for the rest of the time
and now it's been completely fixed.
So don't worry about me.
Good.
I'm totally good.
I'm not.
So no bad omen.
'Cause we tested it, we
went forward, we pressed on.
Two signs that we should turn around,
we thumbed our nose out
and it all worked out.
Yeah, I agree.
I don't really believe in omens as well.
It's just like you're starting out on the,
I've started watching
the 1883 on the plane,
which I think you've already started.
You've already watched.
I watched it all, it gets better.
Well, it starts great
so if it gets better, count me in, man.
Oh good, yeah.
I loved it right from the get.
Yeah, Jessie will like it too.
Yeah, I ended up watching
all five episodes
that they had on the plane without her.
And I was like, you can catch up
but I'm all in for Tim and Faith man.
Anything they do, I'm in.
And it's so good.
But-
Sam Elliot.
Oh, of course, you start
on the Oregon trail,
you gonna lose some people right at the,
spoiler alert, some people gonna die.
I didn't realize it was
the Oregon Trail until-
They were on a trail to Oregon?
Seven episodes in.
I was like, oh-
Yeah, everything that
happens in video games-
That's why everybody's
dying from dysentery.
Right, exactly, yeah.
But you can't just stop 'cause
it's gonna be hard, man.
Can't just stop 'cause it's gonna be hard.
You gotta pop out gas hole.
Yep.
I had an interesting car situation.
I think last time I told you,
last time we went to visit Locke,
there was a issue with
the rental car company.
We had reserved a large SUV
in order to house everything
that we were moving him in with.
Yeah.
Things that had been shipped down there
and we're putting it all in.
So we requested just a
mid-size SUV this time
for me and Jessie and
Shepherd and then Locke
to be able to take him around.
And we show up at a rental car place,
and just like last time,
and I'm not gonna be one of those guys
that complains about a
specific rental car company
or an airline the way
that some people would,
a Twitter following will do.
I get it, but I'm not gonna
do that, I have lodged,
I found out that it is lodge a complaint.
You stick it in the crevice,
you cram it in there.
I have lodged my complaint
with this company
as I waited in line to find out that
the reason that everyone
was waiting in line
instead of just immediately going
and getting into their car like usual,
was that they didn't have enough cars.
But what they did have was
a whole lot of minivans.
Yes.
I mean, minivans for days.
Nobody wanted them.
Well, I go to the lot, he's like,
"Sir, you're in spot J23," or whatever,
and I go over there and
that's when I realize that
they've got no cars but 40 minivans.
I don't know what they
think everybody in Miami,
Miami, that's where we
were, wants minivans,
'cause it doesn't feel
like a very minivan place.
But, I gotta tell you-
Can't be beat, cannot be beat.
... I am just more and more
appreciating the minivan.
It's funny because I'm moving
into this stage of my life
where I don't really need one
because the kids are leaving.
But I think I might be,
our first empty nest purchase
might be just a minivan
for me and Jessie.
Dang, I know that ain't true.
There's so many ports.
That is not true.
Well, and you know what?
They said, "Sir, we have either
a convertible or a minivan."
A convertible minivan?
The only choices they had,
convertible or minivan.
Why didn't you get a convertible?
Well, because there's a family of four
that I'm gonna be taking
around in this thing.
Yeah, okay, all right.
Shepherd was not happy about this choice.
He wanted the convertible.
It was also,
it was forecasting to be
raining most of the time,
most of the days it was gonna be raining
at least part of the time, so ...
But when faced with a
minivan or a convertible,
I mean, those are the
two ends of the spectrum
when it comes to car choices.
It should make it easy.
I think you made the right choice.
I felt like I was in a dream.
This is not the kind of thing
that you should have to
make a decision about
at a rental car place.
"Sir, we have the coolest vehicle
and the most uncool vehicle.
Which kind of person are you?"
Form or function?
That's not a dream, I'll tell you a dream.
Oh, okay.
Christy told me, we were on our trip,
and I was like, "How'd
you sleep last night?"
Because when you don't have kids around
and you're just drinking your coffee
and enjoying each other,
you can ask things like,
"How'd you sleep last night?"
And she's like, "Well
I had this weird dream
that I had to pee.
And actually, I was afraid,
part of me was afraid I
was gonna pee in the bed.
But I started peeing
and then I realized I wasn't on a toilet,
I was on a hamster cage."
No problem there.
Newspaper suck it right up.
No, she said, "I was peeing
on a hamster, and it drowned."
She killed a hamster with her piss.
And she said, "It had a napkin over it."
After it died?
No.
She slowly pulled a napkin over it?
Don't want anybody to see that.
She said, "I looked down
and it had a sopping wet napkin over it."
I guess it was snuggling in his bed.
No, I don't believe in omens,
but I do believe in dream interpretation.
That's a dream, my friend,
She killed hamster by
drowning it in her urine.
That is some hardcore,
I mean, I ain't yelling at her
on the side of the road anymore,
you know what I'm saying?
There's no joke yelling and you know.
Are you the hamster?
I could be the hamster.
I mean,
are you on a hamster wheel?
You're just endlessly running and working
and grinding yourself down to nothing.
And she's like,
the only way to stop this
pattern is to pee on him.
We had no interpretation.
We were just too baffled by it.
That's a dream, not
convertible minivan, but-
All right.
Well, here's the thing.
When we picked up Locke,
well, actually, Locke
came over to the hotel
that we were staying in, which
was pretty close to campus.
We got in pretty late
and we were actually just expecting
to see him in the morning
'cause that's what we had talked about.
But once we, cause it was
10 o'clock when we got in,
he said, "I wanna see you guys."
So he comes over and it's been what,
a month or so since we dropped him off.
Not long enough, in my opinion.
If the fall break comes,
the parents weekend comes real early.
Too quick, too quick.
But I think the whole idea of it is,
I think this is multifaceted,
but I think one thing is just like,
we should get the parents
in there pretty early
so they can check on these kids
before they really derail themselves.
They still got time to correct course
before they've dug too big of a hole,
which a freshman can tend to
do in that first semester.
Well, yeah, It's like we moved,
well, you know what,
I'll keep this anonymous.
I might have moved one
of my kids into college
for her second year,
and then the next morning
we went back to see her
and she was like-
You talking about Lily?
"Don't come in our apartment
because there's vomit all over the rug."
All right, she's living that life.
It wasn't hers.
Okay.
Yeah, but somebody threw up.
And Christy was like,
"I brought that rug."
"Just weeks ago."
"Just last night."
Oh, just last night.
Yeah, 'cause we moved her in.
Oh wow, it was a fresh rug.
Just testing it out.
Oh, my god.
A little peeing on the
hamster, if you will.
Oh, man.
I'm throwing my whole family
under our bus in this episode.
I'm gonna get strung out.
Well, so the general report
is Locke is doing great.
He is enjoying himself.
He's doing well in school.
But he's still very much Locke,
which is a guy who is
filled with so many ideas
that come at you in rapid succession.
That's your fault, genetically.
Here's the mistake that I made, right?
I was kind of gearing myself up,
and I'm gonna say this
by way of lesson learned
and then maybe advice to
other parents out there.
We talk often about
the goal being to maintain
the relationship, right?
Preserve the relationship,
that's paramount.
It's more important that
you have the relationship
than you have control, right?
And there's an illusion of control.
And even when your kid is at school,
you still see them and even if they're 18,
you still see them as your child
that you have power and influence over
and you care about them and
you want the best for them.
And so when they come at you
with a bunch of ideas that,
it was just way he was seeing things
and things that he was gonna
thinking about doing and,
there's a slow down, and I immediately,
he triggered dad mode in a hard way.
And I wasn't expecting it
'cause I wasn't even expecting
to see him that night, I was
gonna see him the next day.
And we very quickly return to a dynamic
that often manifests itself
in our family, which is,
Locke's talking at a
million miles a minute
about all the things that he wants to do
and all the things that he's thinking.
And Jessie and I both
go into mom and dad mode
where you're trying to give
advice and course correct.
And it ended up being not
a great initial reunion.
Now, it ended well that
night and we hugged,
said I love you or whatever,
we'll see you in the morning
and gonna go eat somewhere.
But the first thing I did
when I sat down with him
in the morning, I was like,
"I wanna apologize for how I
was reactive to you last night
when we talked,
and I feel like we started
the trip off on bad foot
and I don't want that to
be the dynamic between us.
I trust you believe you,
love you," whatever.
It actually was-
Pretty good.
That was very helpful.
Now, it's still the McLaughlins,
and so everyone has an opinion
and everyone is passionate
about their opinion
and everybody thinks that
they're equally right.
And Shepherd now, he's a
whole thing in and of himself
as a 14 year old,
which the best way I could
describe a 14 year old boy,
and least the one that's in my house is,
is as if someone suddenly got,
they got turned on, slow
motion was turned on.
It is like you're
watching a YouTube video,
and then all of a sudden
you put it on half speed
and everything slows down and gets deeper.
That's what's happened to Shepherd.
He's been stretched from a boy to a man.
I was watching the video where
we took him out in the FJ
during one of the vlogs and
kind of like let him drive.
And his voice is so high,
he's sitting in my lap.
At this point, Shepherd is six feet tall.
His voice sounds like-
He's my freaking height.
His voice sounds exactly like me.
So much so that,
so Shepherd had his own room at the hotel
and when we got there late,
restaurants were closed
and so we just got some food
from the hotel and he was like,
"Dad, can I call and get
some food from the hotel?"
I was like, "Yeah."
So he calls, and then I call from my room
to get me something to eat.
And then the first thing the guy said was,
"Didn't you just call?"
And I was like, "No, that was my son."
So our voices sound the same now.
So that little boy that was on my lap
just a couple of years
ago is now this big man,
but he's still a boy, right?
He's a boy man.
Right.
He's a moy.
And he's moving in slow motion
and he's entering into the
conversation like this.
It's like he's becoming an ant.
And boy, getting him up,
waking a 14 year old up.
So we had to have a discussion,
a lengthy discussion
about what sound he needed
to pick for his phone to make
in order to wake him up,
because he sleeps through multiple sounds.
That there was an alarm.
There was me calling his hotel room phone,
There was me going down there and banging.
And then finally, I was able
to get him up and be like,
"Dude, we gotta go eat."
But despite the fact
that he is become a moy
and is moving in slow motion,
he is still a McLaughlin
and that comes out when we
sit down and somebody just,
it's so funny because this was
not the dynamic of my family.
The dynamic of my family was
my dad would kind of say something
and everybody would just
kind of agree with it.
That was sort of how my family worked.
The dynamic of Jessie's family
is that everybody has an opinion
and everybody is very good at debating.
And it's just like,
hey guys, we're just talking
about what we're eating right now.
That doesn't have to become a debate,
but the way they actually
show love to each other
is by entering into debate.
And so Jessie kind of has that in her.
And then I can adapt to either situation.
I can be like, I'm along for the ride,
or I also have an opinion
and I can defend it.
And so the dynamic that
has emerged in our family
is that we go out to eat brunch,
and we we're in this restaurant
and we realize that
we're talking very loud
and everyone's talking very passionately
about whatever they're saying.
And it's like, I feel like
people are now realizing
how loud we're being and like-
Noticing.
Definitely, definitely.
But we actually,
we had a chance to kind of
like have the meta conversation
about the way that we,
'cause the funny thing Locke said was,
"It's just amazing how
quickly our dynamic returns."
Like, this is the way
that we interact and-
That's comforting.
Well, he's like,
"It's a little bit frustrating
but also comforting
at the same time."
But we talked about our
dynamic and then we were like,
we need to believe the
best about each other.
There's certain topics
that we might bring up
that we disagree about,
that, there's just no reason for us
to talk about those things.
It's like, this is about connecting,
this is about figuring out
what you need at this juncture
and us being there to be
supportive or whatever.
And then we went to a football game.
So I was excited about this
because we just don't, now
that we're in California
and we're so far away from NC State,
if we still lived in the triangle,
we'd probably be going
to NC State home games
for not all of them maybe,
but I definitely would be-
I would be going when you ask me to go.
I'd have season tickets to the Wolf Pack.
And I just love college athletics.
I completely give myself
over to the mania,
to the completely inexplicable mania.
Especially that my only
connection to this school now
is my son's going there, I am
giving them a lot of money.
And they were also playing
Carolina in football.
Gross.
And so I was like,
Am I gonna have to go and watch Carolina
beat another team that I've
now gotten dressed up for?
We went to the student
store, we got the clothes.
We were like, we're ready to go.
I'm completely embracing this.
And yeah, Carolina beat us.
But I also was so into
it that I lost my voice.
I'm still, that game was on-
I noticed yesterday.
... Saturday.
You were real raspy.
Well, what ended up happening
was there was this crazy,
it was one of those things
where everybody started leaving
because it looked like it was over.
But then they started coming back
and then there was this crazy
onsite kick that they got.
But it turns out when
they watched the replay,
the guy had gone out of bounds.
But when they recovered the onsite kick
before we realized that
there had been a violation,
it was freaking nuts.
And that was the point in
which a series of yells
that I do not remember came out of me
and caused me to like
lose my voice for several,
not lose it, but be raspy.
I'm still kind of there.
Blew it out.
So anyway, that was a really good moment.
And Locke was like, "I had so much fun.
I've never had that much
fun at a sporting event."
We ended up having a very,
very sweet time as a family.
And then when we were
leaving, Locke was like,
"This is almost harder than
when you guys dropped me off."
Ha.
Got to meet his friends
and the people he's
connecting with in his dorm.
There was lots of hugging and
I love yous and it was good.
So we did the thing, we did
the parents weekend thing,
checked in, and I feel-
Mission accomplishment.
We were already in very close contact,
in very frequent contact,
much more than we were
even when he was here,
when he was living with us.
But that frequency has
even picked up since then
with multiple texts a day.
I'm sure it'll die back down,
it kind of dies back down a little bit.
But the relationship, which again,
if my goal is preserving the relationship,
maintaining that relationship,
then mission accomplished.
You want to hear about the
person I met in the wilderness?
Yeah.
So we were staying,
it's the same place we
stayed last year with,
had the cabins, Glen Oaks.
Shout out to Glen Oaks.
It got cabins around the Big Sur River.
So you're in the forest, you're
not on like the cliff's edge
seeing the ocean
from this particular point
in like the Big Sur Canyon.
But it's absolutely amazing,
redwoods everywhere,
these cute little cabins.
Last time we went,
they had shut down part of it
because there was a wedding.
And so they do have weddings.
We saw some people walking around in tuxes
our first morning there where
we had a full day there.
But we went down, we found
the Adirondack chairs
and just hung out next to the river.
And it's absolutely beautiful.
I took my shirt off,
get a little vitamin D,
very comfortable.
How warm was it?
And, it was probably 70 degrees.
It couldn't have been more perfect.
Which is chilly to take
your shirt off if you're me.
But like the sun was just
giving you that nice,
giving it the D man.
And at certain points, I just have this,
I like to be to myself, I
like to connect with Christy.
And then at other points
I feel this need to want to
connect with other people.
It is so outta character for me,
but sometimes I get to
a point where it's like,
I like having conversations
with strangers,
when we go to breakfast and I'm like,
"Oh, where are you guys from?"
I don't know.
You think this is that
a character for you?
Sometimes.
Like when I go on a retreat, sometimes,
oh, I don't wanna talk to anybody,
but sometimes I'll get in that
mode, I'll get in that mood.
I saw a couple come down
to the river below us
and the guy was dressed up
like he was going to a wedding,
I guess, this wedding that was happening.
And then he was taking a
picture of his girlfriend
and I was sitting there shirtless
and I was just watching
them and I was like,
you know what?
I kind of want to go down there
and be in the picture with her.
I just think it would be funny.
Well, yeah, funny is one word.
Funny for me.
Ding, ding, ding.
Totally, you know how I am.
I love the funny for me humor.
And I'm telling Christy this, I'm like,
"I'll also take a picture of them together
'cause he's just taking pictures of her.
He looks nice."
And she's like, No, don't.
You don't need to be social with them."
Thank you, Christy.
And they were a little far away,
but he did turn and look
at me and I waved at him.
Okay.
And he did not wave back.
Yeah, 'cause it's a little strange.
Which I took it to mean
that Christy was right.
And then, she pointed the other direction
and there's like a foot
bridge crossing the river,
and this is 300 yards away.
I know you're into football
so you know how far that is.
You think it was three
football fields away?
300 yards.
Three football fields?
Okay, fine.
200 yards away.
Because I mean, that's almost 1,000 feet.
That's, I mean, some people
can't even see that far.
Okay, how far is far enough
that you can see someone
crossing a foot bridge?
Well, imagine yourself out,
the way I think about this-
This is a divergent,
I imagine myself out-
100 yards.
One football field.
And I'm looking across,
I mean, you played soccer, you know.
They were one football field away.
Yeah, that sounds a lot more reasonable.
Okay.
And it's people in tuxes,
groomsman crossing this foot bridge.
And then also-
You found the wedding party.
And I was like, oh, there's the bride.
And I'm telling Christy, I'm like,
"That's the one I want to talk to.
I wanna talk to the bride."
And I know that this is
putting Christy on edge
and it's just funny to me.
And she's rolling her eyes.
And we are talking about the wedding
and how it would be so
beautiful to get married here
and stuff like that.
We're almost talking ourselves
in renewing our vows,
which I'm against.
My vows are still very much intact.
Okay.
Even though they were very Jesus centric
in one sense, you can make an argument
that we need some new vows,
but I also feel like we're doing great.
There's nothing to renew.
It's still going awesome.
Isn't it just about the party?
Well, we can have a party anyway.
Okay.
But then we're sitting there
in the chairs chilling out,
and all of a sudden outta nowhere,
pops this guy in a tux, the groom,
with a photographer behind him.
How close is he?
How many football fields away is he?
I would say he is five feet away from me.
Okay, that's very close.
I mean, popped out of nowhere.
And then I saw behind the
photographer, the bride.
And I'm like, oh, , it is on,
it's time I get to meet this bride.
And the guy's like-
Why?
He's like, "Would you
mind if we kick you out?"
And he was like, "Okay, we're
gonna take wedding photos."
And I was like, "Oh yes, yes, yes, yes."
And I was shirtless, felt a little weird.
I'm scrambling to put my shirt on,
and he's looking at me strange.
And then I was like,
well, I know I'm strange,
but he's like, "Don't I
know you from the Internet?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
I was like, "I'm getting outta
here, you guys take over."
He's like, "Let's get a picture."
So I a picture with the guy.
Shirt on, shirt off?
Shirt is on at this point.
Okay.
The bride's walking up, she's very quiet,
she did not say anything.
'Cause she's probably concerned.
And I'm like, "You look
beautiful, congratulations."
And then all of a sudden,
there was a teenager there and a baby.
And all of a sudden I'm confused.
Is it Instant Family?
And I started thinking
because it was on my brain
that they were renewing their vows.
And for some reason I came
this close to asking them,
"Are you guys renewing your vows?"
Wouldn't that be the
stupidest thing to ask someone
who's getting married?
Yeah, yeah.
I didn't say it, because instead he said,
"I'm from Naked and Afraid."
And I'm like, "What?"
Okay, all right.
I was like, well we were already leaving.
You're getting married.
You don't have to drop the fact
that you're in a reality competition show
where you're naked and surviving.
But it's like, okay.
But he knew you from the Internet
So he knew me, I guess
he was trying to get-
What did he look like?
He was a tall, strapping,
bearded man, middle-aged.
Okay.
Did he look anything like me?
I mean, you said tall and
strapping and bearded, so-.
Yes.
Because there's multiple people who have,
I don't watch Naked and Afraid.
Well, I don't wanna spoil it
'cause I think that the season's not out.
And I didn't ask him if he won
or lost or whatever or like-
Is he a recurring character
or he hasn't been on yet?
What do you mean a recurring character?
It's just like Survivor, I think.
I think some people,
the best of come back.
Oh, I don't know.
And people have said they
thought that I was on it.
You're dropped in the wilderness.
People who think that
just a tall bearded guy
is always me.
I'm sure there's plenty
of tall, bearded guys
on Naked and Afraid.
Yeah 'cause I mean,
if you're tall you're gonna end up bearded
'cause you're out there anyway.
You start tall, you're
gonna become bearded.
Yeah, well more than one beard, you know?
Right, yeah.
See all the beards
That's really more of a mustache.
So that's the guy that I met.
And then I'm like-
Did you ask any questions about the,
did you talk to the bride?
I said, "You look beautiful."
She was like, didn't wanna say anything.
So then we just kind of left.
They got married.
What did Christy say?
She was just kind of like.
She wasn't talking to them.
She was shooing me out of there
'cause she didn't want
me to be too talkative.
And yeah, turns out they got married.
And then Christy and I are hanging out
for hours in our cabin,
having a grand old time.
And then we both had to use
restroom at the same time.
So I was like, I'll just go down to,
there's more of like a cabin
is like public restrooms,
and I'm gonna walk outta
our cabin and go there
while you're using our bathroom.
Yeah, while she uses the hamster.
Yeah.
So then once I used the
bathroom down there,
at this point I was just wearing
a bathrobe and flip flops.
Nothing else.
Okay, that's odd.
I mean, and you are at a resort,
but there is a wedding party wondering.
But they are from Naked and Afraid, so-
So once I exited the bathroom,
instead of going back to
the cabin, there was a path,
and I'm like I'm just
gonna walk this path down
through this beautiful forest.
And I found myself just
having this contemplative time
where I was just enjoying nature,
walking around in my stark
white robe and my flip flops
on this little path, trying
not to get poison ivy.
And all of a sudden,
these two 14 year old boys
dart around the corner wearing tuxes,
and they stumble upon me
and almost run me over.
And I'm like, I gotcha.
So I talked to these,
it turns out that this 14 year old boy,
a moy, I guess you would call him.
Was he moving in slow motion?
He was.
His dad was Naked and Afraid dude.
Okay.
Who just got married.
So he had been in the photo shoot earlier.
So I talked to him for a while
Did he recognize you?
He did, he was like, "You're that guy."
I was like, "We're all just people.
How long have you known your friend here?"
We're all just people.
Yeah, and he was like, "Three years."
And I was like, "That's a
full third of your lives
that you've known each other."
Of course that was not true
No, not true.
I realized that later
Almost a fifth.
Right.
But I was just trying
to give them something,
like give them some perspective
on life that, it's like-
You gave them some perspective.
'Cause we've known each other for like-
What was a third of your nine years?
... like 90% of our lives
we've known each other.
Maybe more than that.
And then, so I was just trying
to give them perspective.
It's like, it's good to have a friend.
Yeah, it is.
It's great to have a friend.
But they were probably thinking,
why is this naked dude in a robe
talking to me about incorrect math?
How did this conversation go?
What did they say back to you?
And what did-
They didn't wanna be as philosophical
as I felt like I wanted to be.
The forest tends to do these things,
it's like I was on a
retreat and they're getting,
I was like, they had
already gotten married.
They were taking pic,
I was like,
"You guys are running from
pictures, aren't you?"
They're like "Yeah, they want
to take a lot of pictures."
I was like, "You just need to party.
Don't worry about pictures."
That's what I told them.
They're gonna tell their
friends about this interaction.
Who knows what the hell they're gonna say.
So then this is like 30 minutes.
Who knows what you've done to the brand.
When I walked back up to the cabin,
Christy was standing there in her robe
with her hands like, "What the
hell, where have you been?"
Wait, how long was it you think?
Half hour, 20 minutes.
To use the bathroom.
Yeah.
And she was like,
"I just knew that you were
trying to crash the wedding.
You were trying to crash the wedding."
I was like, "Well no I wasn't,
I was just taking a walk."
But we did get invited
to the reception, so,
and they really want us to go.
And 'cause I saw the Naked and Afraid guy
when I was coming back and he was like,
"We're going to the reception right now,
you guys should come."
I was like,
"Well, if I can talk Christy
into it, we'll be there."
And I'm just in my rob.
It's a big if.
I'm like, I like to party,
but I'm not really
dressed for the occasion.
And I made sure that my
junk wasn't hanging out.
That's good.
When I told Christy,
"We've been invited to
the wedding reception,
let's get dressed, let's go right now."
And she's like, "Who invited you?"
I was like, "Naked and Afraid guy,
and his son and his brother."
And she's like, "Did
the bride invite you?"
And I was like, "Well, she was there.
She was sitting in the
car waiting to leave.
But I kept talking to
Naked and Afraid guy.
So they were kind of delayed.
But she never invited me."
And Christy's like, "Exactly.
We can't crash their wedding reception
and make this about you."
I'm like, "You know what?
I respect that."
So we didn't go,
I'm glad you have a wife.
She's so great.
She is my rock.
Can you imagine
if you did these things alone?
She's my rock.
She gives me freedom to just to let loose.
I know that she's there for me.
I feel the same way
about you a lot of times.
Well, it's a lot of work.
I mean, listen, I don't go on
retreats with just you, so,
but God bless your wife.
I love her to death.
She's amazing.
She needs a raise.
Oh, I gave her a raise.
Okay, I see what you mean.
I love Big Sur, man,
It just puts you in a-
I would just love to hear that story
from the perspective of
any one of the people
that you talked to, but
most especially the bride.
Christy said, "I knew you
were naked and I was afraid."
Ah, yeah.
She's brilliant.
And then she was like, "You know what"
That's what we should be for Halloween.
You can be naked and I'll be afraid."
That's pretty good, that's pretty good.
She was like, I can just
be my, and she's like,
"I tend to be more afraid about things
and you tend to be prone or
wanna be naked about things."
I teased at the beginning
that I would talk to you
about the tortilla margarita
that got posted on the Internet.
So Jessie took me out
to a birthday dinner.
And we were going to this place in LA
that Jessie completely
nailed the description of it,
which is, it's a place that
kind of embodies the thing
that people think Los
Angeles restaurants are,
but actually aren't.
Okay.
Meaning, everything is
completely over the top
and super showy.
And it's sort of a you do this one time
and you probably won't come back.
This is how I feel about it.
Gimmick?
Gimmicky, but in a, let me just,
I'll just take you through
a little photo essay
and I will describe these photos
for those of you who are listening.
So just the two of us,
originally we were gonna take Shepherd,
but he was moving too slow.
And just, he basically
had become stationary.
No, he had like a bunch of
homework to do and he is like,
"Sorry dad, I've got too much homework."
And we were kind of like,
you know, this will just be
a date between the two of us.
Maybe even better.
Great.
Have you said the name of the restaurant?
It's called Barton G.
And it's an experience.
Like I said, the food was good,
but it's not really about that.
It's about the presentation.
So it started off and the
waiter said this right up front.
He was like,
"Everything you order
here is gonna kind of come
with a little bit of a show."
I didn't know exactly what that meant,
but I did-
A little bit of a show.
I did pick the, I mean-
The first thing you order here
is gonna have a tortilla on.
So this is a picture that my wife took
of me and my drink, which
it was just some margarita.
I'm obviously, at this
point I'm very, very happy.
I'm just content to be
with my wonderful wife
on my on my birthday.
And there is a tortilla that
is on top of the margarita.
Actually-
It looks like an adult version
of a kid's sippy cup lid.
Like you've popped through
the tortilla with the straw.
Yeah, this was called the La Playa-Rita.
So you can't really see in the picture,
but there's a picture frame below it
and it's sand and a starfish, so like,
oh, we're putting this
margarita on the beach on your,
I mean, not too flashy,
just sort of like, okay,
it's on this frame and
it's got a tortilla.
Okay.
All right, I was like,
I mean it's odd, and I did
eat, yes, the entire tortilla.
Were you supposed to?
Why not?
I mean, I believe it was edible.
So then we got a-
You ate it and you're still saying,
I'm still open to the fact
that it might not have been edible,
but I did eat it.
And now things picked up a notch here
when we ordered the Caesar salad,
which was one of the best
Caesar salads I've had,
I will say that.
I like a good Caesar salad,
especially if it's real strong.
And of course,
the Caesar salad came with
a bust of Julius Caesar.
As you can see, I'm a little
bit intimidated and perplexed.
Is that made out of cement?
It's rock hard man.
Oh.
Yeah.
And it is a little bit odd to eat a salad
while Caesar is at your table.
It's just so weird.
It's not even part of the
salad, it's just a statue.
Oh, you just wait, friend.
Then we order the,
I actually went kinda light
on the number of things that we ordered
because, you know, so we got that salad,
then we got a highly
recommended appetizer,
the lobster pop-tarts.
That sounds good.
And as you can see,
they come in a toaster, right?
Uh-huh.
They were very tasty.
But it-
How much lobster was in there?
Did they skimp?
No, they actually went
real hard on a lobster.
I mean-
Oh, great.
They didn't skimp at all.
At this point, I told Jessie,
at this point, I said-
That makes sense, in a toaster.
"This is, A,
something that the Mythical Kitchen
would make for us on the show,
and B, how they would present it to us."
You know?
Yeah.
And so I was like, "I feel
like I'm on my show now."
Okay, but not in a good way.
No, I was enjoying myself
but then things got a little
bit crazy 'cause I ordered,
well you know what?
I'm gonna come back to that
'cause that's the kicker.
I ordered something that
was a little underwhelming.
It was the fish.
Is that on your head or in front of you?
Well, Jessie thought that
this would be a cute way
to take the picture.
It's hanging, it's a fish that's on a rod
hanging over a fish that you're eating.
So it's a little bit weird, right?
A little bit weird.
Fish was pretty good.
But then they brought out the short rib,
and this was three full beef ribs.
I actually have so much of this left over
because we didn't put hardly a dent in it.
But it came out on top of a lawn mower
that took up the entire
table, the entire table.
Because it's grass-fed.
So, and here's a video.
So that is a push lawn mower?
Yeah, here's the video
complete with sound.
It's a video.
It's making a whole lot of noise.
The lawn mower is taking the whole table.
This sorta came by.
What?
And it makes a scene, it's loud.
It's a lawn mower, now
there's like a speaker
inside of the lawn mower.
It's making all this noise.
I don't know how to feel about this.
It's so easy to poo poo it, but
I don't wanna just go there.
Well, let me just say,
as somebody who eats weird on the Internet
for a living,
and has people make weird
things to bring it out in,
even I was beginning to
get a little embarrassed.
And I don't like to draw
attention to myself,
but everyone at the restaurant
is drawing attention
to themselves over and over again
because that's the whole
point of the restaurant.
So this lawn mower is
coming out multiple times.
You've seen the lawn mower
on other people's tables?
No, actually I saw it first for me,
but then we got there
a little early I guess,
but then I saw it
multiple people's tables.
Actually it wasn't that crowded.
I think people in LA
are maybe a little bit over
this concept, we'll see.
But it was also a weeknight.
How did they put it on the table?
Did it take two people?
Yes, but here's what they did.
They brought it out, they set it down,
and then they come to you and they say,
"Did you get your pictures or whatever?"
And then they take it away
and then just bring you back the meat
'cause you can't eat with that lawn mower,
it takes up the whole table.
At this point, we needed dessert.
And Jessie was like, "What
do you want for dessert?"
I was like, "I want the
least embarrassing dessert."
Wow, your spirit had been broken.
Yeah, I was like-
That says a lot.
I mean,
'cause I had seen a
dessert that had a fork
that was seven feet tall, it felt like.
And also I looked and they had a pie.
It was just like, this is a pie.
The least embarrassing one.
I was like, "What's the pie tonight?"
And they were like, "It's
peach pie with ice cream."
I was like-
Yeah, but what are you going do to me?
That feels-
Peaches, it might come out on a big ass.
So this is that moment.
So they gave you a birthday candle?
Yeah.
What is that?
It is a pie eating contest trophy
with the full pie.
You get a whole pie.
And then they have
multiple empty pie plates.
It's a video.
Do you want a picture now?
The way that Jessie gives
commentary on these videos
is the-
It's not her gift.
It's the running headline.
You buried the lead here that like,
my wife will say some funny stuff.
She's like, "It's a video,
do you want a photo?
It's a lawn mower.
This is what our carne asada came out on."
You know, she does listen to this podcast.
She's gonna have words with you.
I have to give her about
it, it's hilarious.
So it says fifth place on this photo,
and you get a trophy and you
get these empty pie plates.
And again, this is my dessert.
It is a full pie for two people.
So I definitely think if
you wanna have fun, I think-
What would Shepherd have been doing,
would he have been cringing?
He would've been more
embarrassed than me, he's 14.
Now, I think that this could
be a good group outing.
I do think it's worth
going out as a group,
because again, the portions are huge-
This is our profession, though.
The meat, the short
rib, which tasted great.
You could have fed five people,
and of course a whole pie.
We each ate a slice of that
and I've got like a whole pie
in my fridge now.
We could go one or two directions.
We could make fun of this
or we could invest in it.
It's kind of like the
minivan or the convertible.
Well, you know what?
One of the things Jessie
and I talked about
when we were eating there was, I was like,
I don't think I would do this again
because I get it, I saw how it is.
I'm much more interested
in just eating good food
at a cool place.
But it did make me think
about some of the things
that we've talked about, years
ago, really pre-pandemic.
We talked about, and people, I mean,
have asked us about this 100 times.
Like, what would a Mythical
Restaurant look like,
right?
Yeah.
You guys play so many games with food
and you've got all these crazy ideas
and what would it looked like?
And so we've concepted some
different restaurant ideas
that incorporate playing with your food.
But the thing that hit me is
I think I would go to
a place like that and-
It needs to be in a tourist trap.
Doesn't need to be-
Yeah, you gotta get people
who are in the right mood
to be like-
It's gotta be on a pier.
I want to have an experience right now.
And so you gotta, you are totally right,
it's gotta be in a place
where people are like,
we're here to have fun.
'Cause honestly, I want
a good thing to eat in a-
People who are saying, "What
do we want for dinner?"
Well, been there Bubba
Gump that, what's next?
You know what I'm saying?
Well, it's kinda like the Rainforest Cafe.
Which the food is not as
gimmicky as the atmosphere.
Which is very moldy.
And it has definitely passed its prime.
And the prime wasn't even that impressive.
I don't ever order the prime.
But I don't know, it made
me think twice about that.
First of all, I just opened a restaurant.
Just feels like a fool's errand.
Somebody will probably talk us into it.
I am not gonna share.
I'm gonna save my given time,
I'm gonna save my story
of my intimate encounter.
But I do wanna leave you-
Oh, I thought, so the story
of meeting Naked and afraid
wasn't the intimate encounter?
No.
It got more intimate than that?
Than being in a robe on a trail?
Well, I mean, what are we
talking about next week?
What's on the docket?
We can give a little teaser,
and I maybe I can add this to it.
The MythiCon live episode.
Oh, the MythiCon live
episode comes out next.
All right.
So what we just experienced in
MythiCon is our next episode.
What about after that, what
are we planning on doing?
[Inaudible]
Right, maybe I can throw
it in there, I don't know.
Or maybe we make it a Car
Biscuit, I don't know.
We'll talk about, but I
do wanna leave you with,
first of all, I'll leave
you with this picture of me.
Christy took a picture
of me and the sunset
holding a glass of wine,
she told me where to look.
So I feel like this should be the cover
of like AARP or something.
I look like-
It has a brochure-like quality,
It has a brochure-like vibe.
And I just look like, I don't know.
Now, this is the same
place that Jessie and I
got all of our anniversary pictures taken.
See there's me looking at the sun setting.
That's not good enough.
She said, "Look to my left,"
then I become AARP material.
And we went on, it's the same
place that you guys went.
And we went on this amazing hike
and we go to this,
there's like all of this ocean fog
coming in up the cliff and
then over the redwoods,
and we're hiking in this meadow.
All of a sudden we come outta the woods
into this beautiful meadow,
and we walk around the meadow
and then I look back and the sea fog
or whatever it's called,
I took this TimeLapse video, look at that.
That's just like something out of
a Lord of the Rings
spooky horse chase scene.
I mean, it's the most
beautiful place I've been.
Isn't that amazing?
I mean-
Big Sur's most beautiful
place I've ever been.
Ah, I love it.
I love it so much.
So that's what I'm gonna leave you with
and I'll share that other
story at another time.
We've packed so much into this
episode and you've made it,
you've made it to the end.
Unless we pissed you off at
the beginning and you didn't.
And you're not here anymore.
And I'm, you know.
Yeah.
You don't know.
You don't know what
we're talking about yet.
I had fun.
You know what?
I'm grateful.
Forever grateful, forever grateful.
I'm forever grateful.
I'm gonna give you a little rack.
You probably have heard of this musician,
but I've been recently introduced to her.
Yola.
Have you listened to Yola?
Yola?
Yola with an exclamation point?
Uh-uh.
Oh, she is incredible.
What type of music is Yola?
Well, as she says on her Twitter bio,
she is musically genre fluid.
Okay.
Six-time Grammy nominee.
I got introduced to her because
people were talking about,
and this is very humbling,
some people were talking about her and me
in the same sentence
in terms of kind of an approach to music,
which, I'll take it.
And especially with my first
track on my album, Believe me,
which has that kind of throwback,
she has this throwback meets
soul meets country, at times,
and I think that's where the conversation
cross over with me.
She's got some really good country songs.
Oh, her new album is
produced by Dan Auerbach,
from the Black Keys, okay.
And that's a great album.
My suggestion is that
you start with her album,
Walk Through Fire, and just
that first song, Faraway Look,
is just immediately like,
this woman is doing
something very, very special.
All right, all right.
She is singing her ass off.
I'm gonna check this out.
And the production is just wonderful.
So Yola with an exclamation point.
Oh, she appeared on the High
Women Collaboration album
and the Elvis.
Yeah, yeah.
She's in the High Women-
Soundtrack.
With Brandy-
Oh, she's not in the High Women.
It's four-
Oh, well she's in-
High Women is four White
women, she's a Black woman.
She's in that but she's in that song,
the High Women's song.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
It's got a Amanda Shires,
and then Maren Morris-
Gotcha, gotcha.
Who else?
Brandy Carlile, who else?
I can't remember
Okay.
All right, I'll check this out.
Highly recommend it.
All right, so, Walk Through Fire, 2019.
In the meantime,
hey, we'll be at MythiCon next
time you're hearing from us.
Hope to see many of you there.
Hope to have many of you
join us for the live stream.
No, that's already happened.
Oh, yes.
So forget that.
Well, I'm just saying that,
and I'm retro future at this point.
Thank you for those of you who
join us for the live stream,
and join us at MythiCon.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
1-8888-EARPOD1.
EARPOD1.
Hi, this is Cassie.
My fiance and I will be getting married
in October 21st, 2023.
A year from the day that I am calling.
I would love to invite Rhett and Link.
They've never done this.
So how about being the
first one to my wedding?
Hi, this is Paige from Michigan,
and I just wanted to say
on behalf of all veterinary
medical Mythical Beasts,
we're so glad that you adopted a dog
and that you didn't by a puppy.
So I hope that you and Sean and Barbara
have a wonderful life.
Just wanted to throw that out there
and give you a little
appreciation for that.
Love ya, bye.
Hey, guys.
I just wanna say love you
guys, love the podcast.
My boyfriend and I listen
to you all the time.
Make sure we catch every
single new episode.
However, we also listen to you guys, GMM,
Mythical Kitchen and Ear
Biscuits as background noise
while we work from home.
So our dog, I heard this similar
caller had a similar thing,
has really bad separation
anxiety, but when we leave him,
the only time he doesn't cry
is when we put on an
episode of Ear Biscuits.
I think because he associates it
with you guys being his
friends and being home with us,
I think he thinks of you
guys as like actual people
in his life and it's super cute
and it's something we've
only recently discovered,
but it's totally cured
his separation anxiety.
So thank you so much.
All right, have a good one.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.